so there is devastating just devastating
new evidence in the Trump Ukraine
quid-pro-quo Fiasco and it is really
important to understand what we mean by
evidence and I think this is really
worth doing so I'm gonna focus on that
element today and I hope that this is
useful there is new testimony under oath
from the United States envoy to the
Ukraine who says that listen the story
we've been getting publicly is true
Donald Trump indeed made the security
aid hundreds of millions of dollars in
security aid to Ukraine contingent on
dependent upon Ukraine publicly saying
that they were going to carry out this
politically motivated smear
investigation against Joe and hunter
Biden that is as a fact not very
surprising to people in my audience I
presume who have been following the
story but this is the really important
part that I want to focus on today if we
go back to the Russia probe and carry
through to what is going on now with
Ukraine and the impeachment inquiry the
Trump is right has insisted time and
time again that there is no evidence
that everything that there is in the
Trump Russia probe with the Ukraine
Fiasco it is hearsay and people's
baseless allegations and this is why we
have to be just super crystal clear here
because unless we are prepared to
address this farcical claim they're
going to get away with it okay testimony
under oath is evidence now there is a
difference between evidence and sort of
caught red-handed irrefutable proof but
before we even get to that we have to
understand how they are distorting what
actually counts as evidence and before I
go into this let me give you an analogy
which i think is useful here consider
the word theory okay the word theory has
one meaning in colloquial usage and it
has another meaning in the world of
science in science when the when the
term theory is used we're talking about
a group of propositions that explain
facts or explain some real-world
phenomena for example the theory of
evolution
that is a very specific meaning in the
world of science but the word theory in
popular culture in colloquial usage has
a different meaning and theory in
colloquial usage often actually means
what in science is called a hypothesis
which is it's sort of like a starting
point or it's a possibility it's one of
many possibilities for explaining
something in the real world and one of
the things that the American right-wing
loves to do is for example in the
context of climate change deliberately
miss state or flip between definitions
of what they mean by theory they'll just
deliberately distort the definition of
theory by switching back and forth
between the scientific definition and
the colloquial usage which really means
hypothesis they'll say you know a theory
about climate change a theory is just
one of 20 30 or 40 different
explanations about what's going on well
hold on a second that may be what it
means in colloquial usage but when
science call something a theory it has a
different meaning now let's go back to
this evidence thing bearing in mind this
analogy from you know theory hypothesis
all along Republicans have said there is
no evidence for anything in the Russia
probe there is no evidence of any quid
pro quo in the Ukraine Fiasco sometimes
they'll also use the word hearsay
they'll say it's all hearsay what they
mean is no one has been caught on video
in a cartoonish out of the movies sort
of red-handed way that satisfies them as
irrefutable proof but here's the really
important thing sworn testimony is
evidence William Taylor the United
States envoy to Ukraine provided sworn
testimony to lawmakers where he says
there is no question that Donald Trump
was withholding aid in order to try to
get Ukraine to smear Joe Biden and
hunter Biden publicly so now the
trumpets are coming in and they're
saying hold on a second what William
Taylor says is not evidence it's merely
hearsay which is also the wrong word but
let's forget that for now we're not
gonna get into hearsay right now
sworn testimony is evidence sworn
testimony is evidence made under oath or
affirmation under penalty of perjury now
someone could give sworn testimony and
be lying someone could give sworn
testimony and not remember the facts
correctly but when the right says there
is no evidence that's either a lie or an
ignorant understanding of what evidence
means the testimony is evidence but
here's where the theory versus
hypothesis thing comes back to be useful
they're also using evidence
interchangeably with proof this is the
other game that they're playing William
Taylor giving evidence that Donald Trump
withheld aid in a quid pro quo for Joe
Biden to be smeared is not irrefutable
proof that that took place and that's
okay but what they are often saying when
they say there is no evidence is that it
is not a refutable proof which is a
completely different standard it's a
completely different issue
so now understanding this all of this
relates to the total and complete lack
of critical thinking and epistemology
skills in our society which I've been
sounding the alarm about for years at
this point when people understand how
arguments are made when people
understand how to figure out for
themselves if the words being used to
describe things are the most accurate
and precise words that could be used you
can't trick people like this the climate
change theory hypothesis games the games
around what counts as evidence versus
proof you can only get traction with
distortions and lies you can only
confuse people semantically when people
don't have the skills to think these
things through for themselves and that's
really the tragedy that's really the
saddest thing of all about the status
quo of American just ability to think
critically now some last thoughts about
the substance of the testimony from
William Taylor the US envoy to Ukraine
just to kind of come full circle and do
at least some small analysis of that
although it doesn't really warrant much
of an analysis because we know what's
going on number one the testimony is
truly devastating to the Trump narrative
because everyone involved who has given
testimony
including testimony about their
knowledge of that Trump phone call with
the Ukrainian president even Mick
Mulvaney without realizing it without
meaning to everyone is confirming
elements of the story that the aid was
contingent upon the smears of Joe Biden
now after the fact they'll deny it
they'll try to go back and again play
semantic games about the definitions of
the words that they used but that is the
trend
everybody's confirming the original
story even if they don't mean to
secondly this also seems to have
jump-started Fox News back into state
media mode where you know we've talked
about there have been recently some
disagreements between Fox News and
Donald Trump on some minor issues the
last 24 hours the testimony from William
Taylor has completely restarted Fox
News's narrative around the entire
Ukraine thing is a nothing burger it's
all a smear attempt against Donald Trump
it's all a witch-hunt etc they covered
this story about William Taylor's
testimony as if the testimony from
William Taylor is obviously not credible
and suggests that the Trump witch-hunt
narrative is the correct one which I
mean imagine being that disconnected
from reality that that's your takeaway
and again to go back to the conversation
between Donald Trump and the Ukrainian
president the excerpt that was released
they initially said it was a transcript
then they said well it's not a
transcript it's it's a summation in
reality it was a partial transcript
Trump released that believing that it
vindicated him anyone who again can
think for themselves can apply basic
critical thinking and epistemology
skills to a document and not be swayed
by the story that Donald Trump tells you
about it you realize that that partial
transcript is extraordinarily damning
when it comes to Donald Trump's
involvement in this quid pro quo we will
see what the future is of this entire
thing I know that there are people in
the audience who from a practical
perspective are saying listen David I
know you're right and it's not just you
that's saying I mean it's anybody who
analyzes the evidence understands what
it is that took place here but it is
going to be hard to get Trump on it and
I don't disagree with you and that's why
all of these in
negations all of these discussions they
need to be properly contextualized in
let's use them to motivate voters to go
out and vote for someone other than
Donald Trump because the most likely
scenario I know that there are other
paths the most likely scenario is none
of this stuff will forcefully remove
Trump from office but if we play it
correctly if we talk about it in the
right way it will motivate voters to go
out on November of whatever the data is
early November 2020 and say no more I'm
voting for somebody else let me know
what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show